el ultraderechista primer ministro
israelí regresa a casa con los objetivos
cumplidos reforzar las relaciones con su
principal aliado en el tablero
internacional eeuu durante la visita
naftalí bennett se encontró con by the
end y con los responsables del
departamento de estado de defensa y de
seguridad nacional con un punto central
en la agenda frenar el armamento nuclear
iraní mientras que washington intenta
reestablecer el acuerdo con teherán que
trampa abandono
ambos todos los efectivos de la visita y
más acordamos reforzar la cooperación
para frenar la carrera nuclear iraní y
tomamos importantes pasos en equipar y
construirla por sierra élite
respecto a palestina by den aseguró
estudiar modos de promover la paz para
israelíes y palestinos pero no repitió
sus palabras de mayo cuando declaró que
la única solución al conflicto es la de
los dos estados de hecho el primer
ministro israelí consiguió mil millones
de dólares para renovar el sistema
antimisiles cúpula de hierro mientras
persisten las tensiones con hamás
anoche las fuerzas de defensa israelíes
atacar gaza en respuesta al lanzamiento
de globos como ya dije operaremos en
casa de acuerdo con nuestros intereses
por lo que a mí respecta el objetivo en
casa es y seguirá siendo jamás
esfínteres el ano
igual que en julio el bombardeo sobre
gaza se produjo a pesar de la supuesta
tregua decretada en mayo
[Aplausos]
como ya es habitual estábamos durmiendo
cuando nos despertó el estruendo de los
bombardeos con todas las paredes dañadas
mi casa ya no es habitable todos los
muebles están rotos
ataques que se suman a las recientes
muertes de palestinos a manos de las
fuerzas israelíes la última la de omar
hassan moussa aguad milk de 13 años
según la ong the fence for children son
73 los menores que el ejército de israel
ha matado este año cifras que dan fuerza
a hamás